because without the ability to influence
and persuade your Kanaks you can't put
yourself out there into the world and be
known for what you really are the only
thing that stops you from getting what
you want in life is the bullsh
Store and you tell yourself of why you
can't have it most people have goals in
life we would Brooke think you got to be
goal-oriented
that's the first mistake wanna soar get
a mentor
[Music]
so today let's learn from one of the
best jordan belfort and some of his best
life-changing advice mentor me Jordan
alright let's kick it off with rule
number one learn to influence and
persuade Warren Buffett was doing the
speech of Bill Gates about me ten years
ago
and he was asked by a college student
what can we do as students to make
ourselves more valuable in the workplace
so you think Warren Buffett would say
learn how to pick stocks or investments
you know whatever he would say not what
he says he says go out and take a course
in sales and conservation there he did
Dale Carnegie change his life there you
go now that point because he took they
said I took Dale Kearney changement
without that you don't he'd be without
that course yeah he'd be the richest
money manager in Omaha Nebraska then no
one ever heard of yeah Annie met his
wife that way but the love is life is
without the ability to influence and
persuade your pants you can't put
yourself out there into the world and be
known for what you really are
rule number two be honest with yourself
the only thing that stops you from
getting what you want in life is the
[ __ ] story you tell yourself of why
you can't have it get that what stops
you back is the story because the story
stops from getting honest and if you
can't get honest with yourself there's
no way you can go mad you like this
success in sales in life it's like a
road map right you know where you want
to go and you have this perfect strategy
the straight line to get there it's a
perfect strategy it's gonna get you
there every single time but if you don't
know your starting point it you're not
getting eyes where you actually are it
doesn't matter how powerful the strategy
is and it doesn't matter how powerful
your goal is I'm gonna actually set a
goal today write a 60 day goal and let's
say you really set this goal and I'll
show you how to do it in a brilliant way
so it's visceral
so it makes you really feel it you see
it you sense it you smell the goal
that's step one I'm gonna teach you the
straight line which is your strategy to
get to your goal but if you're not
honest with where you are right now your
starting point the map is worthless
there's three things that you need to
know where you are where you want to go
and how you're gonna get there those are
the three things you must have to take
advantage of any opportunity I'm gonna
give you the strategy I'm gonna actually
tell me exactly where you want to go for
yourself you got to get honest don't
blame the boss don't blame the leaves
don't blame your job don't blame the
industry are in just get out if you
don't like your industry find another
one also if you want to learn how to
have more confidence check in my 250 for
confident series it's free the link is
in the description below the only thing
that stops you from getting what you
want in life is the [ __ ] story you
tell yourself rule number three be a
visionary
most people have goals in life and we
would Brooke thing you got to be
goal-oriented that's the first mistake
yes you need goals but there's something
far beyond goals
which is what all successful people have
and that's a vision it's a vision for
the future see the here's it is you see
things as they are but not worse than
they are yeah which is what a lot of
people do yeah they say oh it's so
terrible they tell themselves this wild
story about why they can't take action
and in truth the story they tell
themselves is exactly what holds them
back from being successful okay it's
that bull story that stops from acting
like and they're all there's so much the
economy and they play the blame game
they complain they justify and it stops
them from moving forward so see things
as they are not worse than they are you
know and then see them better than they
are
yeah and make them that way look at a
Gandhi right he survived hunger strikes
in the United the country not because he
had a goal for free and yet he had a
vision of a free India Nelson Mandela
all those years in jail on vision yeah
it's Richard Branson who's a friend of
mine who I know he sponsors me my
speaking to her he's a good visionary
Bill Gates are all visionaries and the
best example consider we're in Hollywood
is a guy like James Cameron now here's
the trap James Cameron is probably the
greatest visionary of all time in
filmmaking that we do a great there he
was a food on Diane Sawyer and they
asked him a question of what do you owe
your success to and what he said was
this I said really really high goals so
even if I fall short I'm still doing
great and people thought that was pretty
profound and I actually believed in that
too it's not true though see what's
happening is this James Cameron is that
goal center he's a visionary he just
doesn't realize because he's running
unconscious strategy himself you said
the crisis of James camels are really
just the goals your vision for avatar
he'd say oh of course I will
and he'd get all excited me tell you how
nothing was gonna stop him from making
this movie the fact that it took ten
years and ran 200 million over budget he
put money in himself or that's not the
goal setters do bowl setters will set a
goal gets up and they abandon it and I
can't overemphasize that distinction
that's number one whose vision rule
number four learn to sell for like an
entrepreneur not a sales but about just
an entrepreneur who's looking to start a
business well if you can't sell if you
can't influence if you can't persuade
good luck trying to get your business
off the ground I'm not just your
customers I'm talking about the bankers
the people of venture capitalists your
vendors your credit card processor the
people who work for you how do you get
people to work for you
excited how do you get them excited you
get them to want to buy into your vision
at the highest level what sales really
is the transference of emotion and the
emotion you're transferring is this
emotion of certainty that some feel
certain yet it's a good thing it's gonna
help me it's gonna fill my need when
you're an entrepreneur you're trying to
start a business and you're recruiting
people well you're selling people on
your vision for the future your vision
for this company if you can't do that
good luck trying to get great people to
work for you it's very it's almost it's
nearly impossible which is why you what
we see you know the people if they say
oh he's a visionary
well that's true but typically not only
are they visionaries they also possess
the ability to sell the vision to other
people to inspire them to motivate them
so selling is not just like you know
people think of selling oh well a lot of
salesmen I don't he thought well yes you
do you need to learn how to influence
how not trying to get your kids to make
their bed or do that homework or believe
in the value of education how about
trying to get a landlord give you a
reduction on your rent ought to extend
the lease of the way you want I'm not
trying to negotiate terms you understand
it it's it cuts to everything so I
always looking to say you know when I
say I crack the code on influence what I
really did essentially was I just I was
you know by working
it's almost by saying i'ma start at the
end and go to the beginning say what has
to happen before someone says yes I was
able to take that and put it into the
system that took the no-name talentless
skies and turn them into millionaires
rule number five manage your standards
on some levels your standard you just
feel like a thermostat it's gonna end up
now your standards is not a constant way
like this is my standard if you have a
standard in any given moment in time
you'll be stopped the above your
standard it's like the lawyer standing
but that standard it really dictates
sort of where you end up over the long
term
so there's many people out there for
instance that you know they have stand
that they need to make $200,000 a year
so they make $200,000 a year because
what happens when they go over that hey
back off other people have a standing
they make two million I won't sell
clothing two million right those people
end up to two million so the idea is
that to first realize what is my
standard and does my standard serve my
outcome is my standard too low is my
standard unreasonable and so because any
you know conflict then this dissonance
between where you want to go what your
actual standard is then you need to
either raise your standard or sometimes
even it could be lowering a financial
standard if it's if it's corrupting the
rest of your life but typically what we
find is that people have financial
stands that are really not serving their
old it low and they could raise them up
and rule number six the last one before
a very special bonus clip is try your
hardest my sons 14 is fabulous and we're
having this conversation about when he
plays in sports or when he does
something about you go full out or do
you not and I see sometimes in him that
when he's out on the field of doing
something he doesn't play full out and
I'll have an excuse like my leg hurts or
my arm hurts or something happened the
coach was unfair what are the hang of
the referee was unfair and what happens
with people is we tend to go out into
the world and we look for those sort of
excuses about why things aren't the way
we want them and when you do that you
lose all your power in life when you
start focusing on the external on the
excuses you lose your power here's the
way people really think I will tell you
I can go out on the stage and bomb you
gonna throw you just bomb right and
people will respect you for going out
there and trying your hardest it's not
how you actually perform that earns you
the respect of your peers it's the fact
that you went out and actually did it
that's the difference so if you're out
there right now you're a new salesperson
or you're struggling as a salesperson
there's no embarrassment in the struggle
it's just not the embarrassment is in
quitting the embarrassment is it not
trying your hardest now we got a special
bonus clip from Jordan on how to manage
your state that I really think you're
gonna enjoy but before that it's time
for the three-point landing questions
let's go from just watching a video to
taking action here we go
question number one where do you need to
be more honest with yourself question
number two what is your big vision and
question number three where do you need
to raise your standards you're an angry
pissed-off negative unruhe social state
you can't do anything well you met one
of those days for instance where
everything you're doing you're like I
can't believe I said that I can't
believe I did that I'm such a fool right
yeah that day we've all had that day
yeah next day similar situation you're
like wow you know that was me I did a
really great job right you were perfect
so one day you're brilliant next day
same situation you're brutal that's not
talent that's not ability that's the
state that you're in so the key to
success is not just a to have your
vision but to be able to manage the way
you feel in the moment now if you're a
parent what's the most resourceful state
patience if you're a businessman looking
to make money on Wall Street it's
probably certainty yeah more courage
because fear is the worst emotion of all
for being a trader on Wall Street so
every business has different states that
you need to master now in most
businesses in matters of wealth is
straight three states that you need to
master feel the trigger and a moment's
notice and it's easy to do what you
learn now we're just going to teach
people okay and number one is certainty
to be certain about what you're doing
the second one is clarity to be clear
it's not gonna be overwhelmed with the
obvious will be overwhelmed and the
third is courage is to how to convict
to know that you might not be right all
time but you get exact let fear stop
because if there's one distinction that
between the wealthy people of the world
and the poor people of the world is that
wealthy people act in the face of fear
while poor people run away from farad
if you want to learn how to master the
art of sales with jordan belfort check
out the video right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
is every sale the same well only if
you're in control see once you take
control of the encounter once you learn
how